aujourd'hui c'est le 1er avril mais
pourquoi fait-on des blagues ce jour là
cette tradition remonterait au milieu du
xvième siècle quand le début de l'année
a été fixée au 1er janvier à la place
semble-t-il du 1er avril
certaines personnes un peu longue à la
détente aurait malgré tout continuer à
s' offrir des présents à cette date les
convertis au nouveau calendrier pour se
moquer l'aurore est à leur faire des
cadeaux un peu ridicule qui petit à
petit se sont transformés en farce et en
blague il poissons dans tout ça selon
certaines sources il serait liée à la
pêche au maquereau qui redémarre au
printemps l'occasion autrefois d'offrir
du poisson d'autres sources suggèrent
qu'il est liée à l'interdiction de la
pêche dans certaines régions on offrait
alors de faux poissons aux pêcheurs
manifestement toutes ces traditions se
sont mélangés dans la marmite du temps
pour donner une drôle de bouillabaisse
et une capsule de déco fine et qui fait
la blague aller à demain et n'oubliez
pas nous sommes confinés
mais on reste en lien si vous avez aimé
cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à laisser un
pouce bleus gens réalisent une nouvelle
chaque jour alors pour ne rater aucune
de ces capsules 2d confiné abonnez-vous
et activer la petite cloche
merci à toutes et à tous et à demain